talking to Ben Shapiro like in his mind
it's Mayhem well yeah because that
dude's at Point Blank you know Ground
Zero for political activities yeah and
thoughts comments and hostility he's
he's ground zero he that's all he sees
all day long oh yeah I can't even
imagine what the world looks like
through his eyes falling apart and even
then even Ben Shapiro kind of someone's
you know these even then the majority of
it if not all of it is from the Internet
or the news oh yeah you know it's and
it's that's the way it looks you know
um look at Rachel Maddow it's the same
thing she's at Ground Zero for all this
stuff so it doesn't matter you can pick
your ground zero and the way the world
looks through their lens is like
freaking total Mayhem